at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands discover
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront is the future of
financial advice they've become
incredibly popular among my friends in
Silicon Valley and across the country
because they provide the same high end
financial advice that the best private
wealth managers delivered to the ultra
wealthy but for any account size and at
a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealthfront now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free
way to invest they don't have bloated
sales teams or retail locations so they
can deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so at the very least
go to wealthfront comm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go to wealthfront comm forward
slash Tim to get your first 15k managed
for free or just to get more details
check it out wealthfront comm forward
slash tim
this episode is brought to you by ID
Commerce and logistics known these guys
for quite a while I'm asked all the time
about how to scale businesses quickly
and rule number one is removing
bottlenecks that slow you down and act
as an emergency brake for many companies
one of the first things that should go
is inventory management and fulfillment
ID commerce and logistics focuses on
helping online retailers and
entrepreneurs outgrow the competition by
handling all of the behind-the-scenes
details that you don't want to they
manage your inventory pick pack and ship
and handle every possible logistics need
so that you can focus on what you're
good at and the other aspects of growing
your business I partnered with them
myself during the launch of the 4-hour
chef so that I could focus on promoting
the book what I'm good at and they
ensured they handled what they're good
at that is keeping my readers happy with
dozens of different products that needed
to be shipped out during holiday crunch
season before Christmas I'd ecommerce
and logistics works with many types of
businesses including ecommerce consumer
packaged goods subscription boxes and
dozens more and they're integrated with
top ecommerce platform such as Shopify
my personal favorite
Magento bigcommerce and others which
makes the set up the integration
partnership all seamless and as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars of startup fees
and costs waived that is a huge discount
so check it out you can go to ID
comluv.com forward slash Tim that's ID c
om l OG com forward slash tim or you can
go to tim blog forward slash scale
that's tim dot blog forward slash scale
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is my job to
explore and deconstruct world-class
performers people who are the best at
what they do to tease out the belief
systems philosophies habits routines etc
that you can use this particular episode
is different for a few reasons and I'm
very excited about it number one we have
our oldest guests to date eighty-three
years which I want to do more of I want
to really Chronicle and investigate some
of these treasures that we have on this
planet and so I may also be going after
Don Wildmon soon if you don't know who
that is you will shortly but this time
around we have someone I've wanted to
interview for decades
literally his name is dr. Philip
Zimbardo at Phil Zimbardo on Twitter he
is one of the most distinguished
psychologists in the world and a
professor emeritus at Stanford
University he is arguably best known for
his 1971 Stanford Prison Experiment in
which students were turned into mock
prisoners and guards for a continuous
24-hour a day study this particular
experiment was planned for two weeks but
terminated after just six days and we
will dig into why that was the case and
he gives a fantastic overview of this
study in this podcast we also explore
how we as humans can do less evil how
you can be a deviant for a day and I
highly highly highly encourage you all
to try this and it's detailed in the
conversation what mindful disobedience
is and much more it was a real blast to
finally get him on the phone after
having read so much of his work apart
from all of that dr. Zimbardo has served
as president of the American
Psychological Association and designed
and narrated the award-winning twenty
six part PBS series discovering
psychology he's published more than 50
books
what including shyness the loose fur
effect the timed cure of the time
paradox and most recently man
interrupted the time paradox is another
one that I recommend to everyone if
you're a fan of the Tony Robbins Dickens
process exercise is outlined in tools of
Titan's you will love that book
dr. Zimbardo currently lectures
worldwide and is actively working to
promote his nonprofit and trust me this
guy at 83 is more active than almost
every person I know so you will feel Eve
you will hear phone calls going on in
the background he's traveling all over
the world so don't let it distract you
anyway back to his current passion and
focus the heroic imagination project
heroic imagination org his current
research looks at the psychology of hue
ISM the question he poses is what pushes
some people to become perpetrators of
evil while others act heroically on
behalf of those in need and that is
precisely among many many other things
what we explore in this conversation so
without further ado please enjoy a
wide-ranging conversation with dr.
Philip Zimbardo dr. Zimbardo welcome to
the show good to be here thank you for
inviting me I have wanted to connect
with you and speak with you and I don't
say this to many people for many many
decades in fact I was a at least for a
period of time a psychology major
technically in neuroscience at Princeton
and was actually a subject in some of
the experiments of Danny Kahneman's and
really yeah I was indeed I thought I
tapped a spacebar for a very long time
in a very dark room and was very boring
but hopefully contributed to the greater
scientific progress in some fashion I
thought I thought we could start with
people who are not familiar with your
work when people think of dr. Philip
Zimbardo what do they tend to associate
you most with in the world of psychology
or science
well my legacy for better or worse is ye
olde Stanford Prison Experiment which I
did back in 1971
I was recently in Budapest and I'm
driving in a taxi and the taxi driver
says you sound like an American I said
yes I said what do you do I said I'm a
psychologist he said did you hear that
study where they put college students in
a
in Budapest Hungary so yeah so it's it's
it's what I'm most well known for
because it was it it is it was and is
the most dramatic study ever done in
psychology in part because it went 24/7
most research is just one hour yeah
typically it fits into a student's as a
curriculum schedule but this pro this
research went on day and night for a
week and it was supposed to go for two
weeks and so what was special about it
is you could actually then see in other
videos we took the character
transformation of hour by hour day by
day good kids beginning to do really bad
things and these were the nine guards
and nine prisoners to begin with yeah so
if you want me to give a you want a
thumbnail overview sure let's get a for
those people love familiar I think it'd
be a great place to start okay so the
year is 1971 it's the 70s exciting
things are happening in psychology a
little bit earlier at Yale Stanley
Milgram who was my high school classmate
and James Monroe High School in the
Bronx in the 1950 he had done the
classic research on blind obedience to
Authority in which he got mostly men
ages 20 to 50 not college students to
play the role of teacher who is going to
help students improve their memory by
punishing errors and the way they would
punish the error is by giving them
escalating levels of electric shock to
their fingers and what happened is the
Confederate who is pretending to be the
student of the teacher began after a
while to yell and scream and say I have
a heart condition I don't want to go on
and the question is would anybody
continue the experiment that kept saying
to the to the real participant
you must go on you have a contract you
must continue teacher and the amazing
thing is two of every three of these
adults went all the way to 450 volts
which in a sense could have been lethal
I should back up and say when Milgram
asked forty psychiatrists at Yale
Medical School what percent of all
Americans would go to the to the bitter
end
their estimate was 1% because to do so
you'd have to be a psychopath so they're
only off by 74% and so the point is it's
two of every three and and so but his
research was part of the demonstration
of the power of social situations over
individual dispositions and I followed
up my team at Stanford Craig Haney and
Curt banks and David Jaffe and I
followed up by saying you know it's rare
that somebody will tell you to do
something horrible or dangerous
typically you're playing a role and in
the role and you're in a group and
everybody is doing this so weary
conceptualize the setting as a prison
and because prisons are all about power
and guards have power and prisoners try
to get some and guards try to limit it
they're there their attempts at power
and so what we did is we put an ad in
the Palo Alto newspaper wanted college
students for a study of prison life that
could go up to two weeks and
seventy-five people answered the ad we
interviewed each of them gave them a
battery of personality tests and we
picked two dozen who are normal and
healthy in every way we could we could
imagine and then what happened was we
randomly assigned have to be guards
after prisoners and and in that setting
they became prisoners or guards now of
course we made it realistic they had you
in a different kind of uniforms prisons
had symbols of power billy clubs
handcuffs military-style uniforms and
the prisoners were in uniforms that
simply had a number on it we took away
the name they'd be
they became dehumanized and the amazing
thing was in 36 hours a normal healthy
college student and these are not
students from Stanford they were from
all over the United States who were in
the Bay Area of finishing up summer
school one of the prisoners eight six
one two
I still remember if it really had an
emotional breakdown screaming crying out
of control and and each day thereafter
another prisoner had a similar reaction
so we ended the study after five days
because it was out of control and we
could not imagine that that a social
situation could have such a profound
impact but what happened was the guards
really became creatively sadistic there
were three guards working eight-hour
shifts on and there were three shifts
and there were nine prisoners at any one
time three in a Cell and then the
remaining there were backup guards and
backup prisoners and so the seti ended
on this very down note of good kids
doing really bad things to each other
creatively evil in the role of guard and
this this has some very wide reaching
implications it would seem and you've
written extensively about this and it
has relevance to many things that are
happening in in our modern day today
including the the Abu Ghraib prison
scandal I suppose you could call it it
was blamed on rogue soldiers but you
were one to point out that it was it was
it was a bigger issue than that it
wasn't you couldn't necessarily isolate
a few bad actors it was more of a
systemic issue yeah you hit it right on
the head is that for your listeners
would just go back in time and 2004
someone released pictures of American
prison guards in Abu Ghraib prison in
Iraq humiliating torturing degrading
sexually abusing prisoners who they
should have been protecting so these are
images that came from the cameras of the
guards themselves and it was a global
disgrace to America at
when the war in Iraq was was still a big
a big problem big issue and and what
happened was again obviously the
military disowned did say this there
were a few red apples and curiously I
was in Washington DC when that broke I
had been the president of the American
Psychological Association and was there
on a on a follow-up visit and someone
from National Public Radio had been my
student at Stanford where I taught for
50 years call me and said hey hey dr. Z
those images that we just showed we're
the same as the images you showed us in
class of the Prison Experiment well
putting bags over prisoners head
stripping them naked etc and so would
you like to come on to be interviewed
and I was and I simply said look my
hypothesis is that most American
soldiers are good apples and what we
have to realize is someone put them in a
bad barrel and we have to know who the
bad barrel makers because that's who
should be on trial not not not the
soldiers at the end of the line and that
became an interesting metaphor bad
apples that's it what's wrong with the
individual versus bad barrels which is
the situational analysis and then of
course the system is the bad barrel
makers people who who make those
situations and sustain them and then I
actually defended ship Frederick who is
a staff sergeant who should have been in
charge of the night shift but he too got
sucked into the frivolity they were it
was said they simply say we're having
fun and games and they did not have any
idea that the images that they took with
their cameras would be released to the
world and a few follow-up questions
related to that is was the big question
in my mind is if if you are someone who
views themselves as a good person or at
worst a neutral person who doesn't want
to do evil how do you avoid the
circumstances or the slippery slope of
evil are there are the
there are things that you can keep in
mind or reminders that you can set for
yourself things you can avoid to help to
mitigate that risk
now Abbey that's a great great way to
frame it is that evil is seductive in
fact Christians around the world say to
their God lead us not into temptation
deliver us from evil and the point is
evil comes in many sizes many shapes
there is the evil of action doing bad
things but there's also the evil of
inaction right not not doing the right
thing when you could so this this is
what comes up in the bystander effect
made famous I guess 60 years ago in New
York City when a young woman was being
assaulted kitty Genovese and screamed
and screamed and people heard and no one
came to her aid
so the bystander metaphor is that people
around the world do not come to the aid
of someone in an emergency who needs
their help and and so this is this so
these are fundamental things is that
it's so easy to cross the line and in
all the research done in psychology the
Milgram study that Sarah president study
and many many other experiment the
curious thing is even though the
majority gives in complies conforms
there was always a minority ten percent
twenty percent sometimes thirty percent
who resist and so we I began to study
what is it about those people who resist
the temptation the power of the group
especially when everybody else in the
group is doing is they come on as fun
and games and so I began to think of
them as everyday heroes I wrote a book
called the Lucifer effect and the
subtitle is understanding how good
people turn evil and the book has ten
chapters on the prison society two
chapters in our grade and then a lot of
chapters on evil around the world Bosnia
Rwanda and then in the end I'm you know
I'm buried
evil I mean it took two years to write
the book and I'm swimming in in a sea of
evil and it was so depressing every
morning to sit at like that's one thing
oh my god okay which evil am I going to
deal with today so in chapter 16 if
anybody in the audience has not read the
book start with 16 and work backwards so
16 is really celebrating the banality of
heroism in the same way that Hana arrant
in the trial of out of Eichmann in
Jerusalem talked about Eichmann as
illustrating the banality of evil that
is here's a monster who orchestrated the
deaths of millions of Jews who looks
like your uncle Charlie and you know who
acts like any know an intelligent Uncle
Charlie because he was he was a you know
a very formal intelligent guy but I'm
and so I used that metaphor to say you
know when we think about hero's we
really you know think about classical
heroes we think about Agamemnon and
Achilles we think about modern heroes
like Gandhi and Nelson Mandela Martin
Luther K mother Teresa but those people
are lifelong heroes
what we should really be thinking is
about ordinary people like any of us
ordinary people who and sometimes do
extraordinary deeds of goodness of
kindness or compassion and we should
think of them as heroes in training that
is each day doing daily deeds of
goodness and kindness that are not
heroic in and of themselves but they
really on a path toward heroism and what
we think is those people when a big
opportunity arises when there is an
earthquake when there is a terrorist
attack they will be the ones more likely
to take a probe and effective action and
and I embodied all of that in a new
program I started in San Francisco back
in 2008 called a heroic imagination
project or hip the idea is heroism
really starts in the mind you have to
think of yourself as I could be a hero
rather than heroism is something that's
a job of other people or is the job of
comic book characters and I'd love to
dig into a few of the things that you
just discussed so the first the first
the first is and I love the the latter
portion talking about the the everyday
here on these components in part because
I believe very much that if we're if
we're looking for I would say patterns
of behavior I tend to agree with one of
my favorite quotes which is our coloca
sit was a Greek poet and is we do not
rise to the level of our expectations we
fault the level of our training so if
you're focusing on these daily behaviors
on a micro level then the the hope is
that on a macro level like you said when
there's an earthquake and a disaster
response or something like that if you
need to triage you'll be the one to take
that step forward I've looked at for
instance the loose for effect and some
of the writing around it and I found
seven social processes that grease the
slippery slope of evil alright and and
I'd love to just read these off and then
ask a follow-up question so the first is
mindlessly taking the first small step
the second dehumanization of others
third deindividuation of self in other
words Anna
then diffusion of personal
responsibility blind obedience to
Authority uncritical conformity to group
norms and then last which you mentioned
the kind of error of the evil of
omission and not commission that is
passive tolerance of evil through
inaction or indifference is it possible
to become more heroic by doing the very
opposite so in other words making these
imperatives the opposites yeah so all of
these I would embed in the broader
context of the importance of situational
sensitivity situational awareness so
Milgram and I highlighted the power of
social situations to dominate
personality but it doesn't mean it's
it's ubiquitous but it doesn't mean it's
inevitable step one is to realize your
vulnerability all of our vulnerability
situational forces come in many
different forms many different shapes
but it's it's always to be mindful of
what is happening around you because and
just to be aware that situational forces
the a group pressure what other people
are doing how you address what the
situation is can influence your behavior
and so some of the things that you had
just mentioned are really part of a
greatest sensitivity to things happening
around you in the social situation
rather than in the physical environment
and if we if we want to go through one
one by one I can just elaborate just a
little bit on each absolutely yes please
so number one was mindlessly taking the
first small step yeah so the conclusion
from the Milgram experiment should be
all evil begins with 15 volts so in the
Milgram study the the participants had
in front of him a big shock box that had
30 switches that began with 15 volts and
increased by 15 volt increments 15 30 45
and of course there was a label above
the mild shock strong the moderate shock
etc
but the key is you know imagine you're
sitting in front of the shock box and
you see at the end it says danger high
voltage 350 volts you know 75 450 you
have to say to yourself you know when I
press this first button what's going to
keep me from continuing to press the
next one and the next one the next one
and and then would I ever want to go to
40 50 both so obviously I wouldn't so
but the point is once you press 15 volts
you are on that slippery slope of evil
because it becomes easier easier and and
when you press 15 volts you know what
nothing happens the guy the guy has even
notice it but 15 volts then is really
like the first time you cheat a little
bit on a test in school the first time
somebody tells you a sexist or racist
joke and you either smile or giggle or
laugh a little bit rather than say I
think that's inappropriate you know so
again it's it to beware that even though
there's nothing truly negative in that
first 15 volts it is literally on the
path of what we consider a slippery
slope of evil it's going to get it's
going to be 35 it's going to be I mean
it's going to be 75 it's going to be a
hundred and then in two out of three
cases it gets to be 450 volts right so
being being very aware of the seemingly
harmless gateway drugs they sure down
the slippery slope right the number two
is dehumanization of others yeah at the
center of all prejudice all
discrimination is thinking about other
people as less than human
so in our prison experiment we took away
people's names which is part of your
humanity we replace them with numbers
they were caught they were eight six one
two four one six three six oh nine and
after a very short time for example in
it when a Catholic priests who had been
a prison chaplain came to see the
prisoners and by request he asked them
what's your name son almost all of them
gave their number in a very short time
they
accepted our dehumanization and became
that number now that dehumanization
takes other forms so by talking about
migrants rather than people who are
migrating out of danger talking about in
San Francisco we have a big problem with
the homeless they're not homeless they
are people who do not have a home so
again it's focusing on these are people
in different circumstances of tragedy
but once you once you once you apply a
label it's just like saying and these
are you know and for italians wops were
dirty jew or something or that kind one
once you put a label on other people you
take away their humanity and then you
could you treat them as less than human
yeah I mean absolutely and I mean this
is can proactively be done of course
with those who orchestrate propaganda
it's I mean it's a meaning warfare
wartime propaganda whether it's a
Goebbels or if you look at some of the
the collateral that was created during
World War two in the Pacific Theater I
mean it's on both sides it's the the
objective is to dehumanize so your
soldiers are more effective in some
cases yeah
Sam Kean who's I guess I would call him
a social philosopher he lives nearby
here in Marin he has a wonderful book
called faces of the enemy
and what he shows in with graphic
visuals that before any nation goes to
war they prepare their people to hate
the other the enemy by having these
visual depictions of them as less than
human and then in the end it's mothers
are willing to send their sons to ward
it actually a guide to to protect them
from the in quote the enemy yeah so it's
really a critical critical aspect now
I'm jumping ahead one of the ways that I
work to prevent that is I am distressed
especially now
in San Francisco with we have cold and
rain no we have hundred and seven
thousand homeless people on the street
many old ladies sometimes families so
each day I decide am I going to give her
50 cents a dollar but I don't just give
money to a homeless person what I do is
I try to humanize them I will pick
someone and down the street and then
simply say hello I'm sure labarda what's
your name and they're often surprised I
shake their hand I give them a doll I
say I you know I wish it could be more I
hope your luck improves and I take one
minute to make to convert that
dehumanizing experience into a human one
and I had a occasion we say where a
woman began to cry because no one no one
had done that simple
okay number three deindividuation yeah
so I I did early research when I was at
New York University before I came to
Stanford simply putting people in mass
putting people in hoods taking away
their visual the visual sense putting
them in the dark
it's it's a Mardi Gras effect we are
able to show that when your identity is
removed and you're in a situation that
gives you permission to be harmful
aggressive you will take it so we did an
experiment at New York University where
we had college female college psych one
females who half of them we put in hoods
and we took away the name they came the
one two three four and half of them we
made feel special and then they had the
opportunity to give electric shock they
thought to other women who were trying
to remember material under stress and
what we found is college women gave
twice as much electric shock to other
women when they were D individuated than
when they were not and so when you're
anonymous it takes away again this links
to another point your sense of personal
responsibility
no one knows and no one cares now again
it goes both ways in the mardi gras if
you're in a situation of fun and
pleasure and enjoyment and lust if you
will people will go that direction so it
means that the D deindividuation takes
away your central organizing principle
of I am responsible for my action and
essentially you then go with the flow
for better or for worse right it removes
these social inhibitions regardless of
the particular type or species of
impulse
whether it's towards lust or aggression
or otherwise the next you you already
alluded to in a sense is diffusion of
personal responsibility yeah so this
ties into the way we're talking about
bystander effect is that ordinarily we
each feel responsible for
our actions we feel responsible for
people around us certainly our friends
and family neighbors and again my hero
project tries to extend that to say you
know the world is my neighbors the world
is it could be my friends and all the
research on the fusion responsibility
simply says that when you see other
people like you passing by someone in
need then they they create a social norm
of doing nothing when you know you
should be doing something and something
sometimes is very very simple helping
somebody up who's falling down and so
it's something that we have to guard
against is that not allowing the social
norm of other people being bad
Samaritans to change your your sense to
be a good Samaritan
now one of the things there's a
fascinating study that you probably know
about it was done by John Darley and his
student Daniel Batson and it was at
Princeton
and Princeton Theological Seminary where
what they did was they got a bunch of
Princeton Theological students kids were
going to become ministers and they said
we're studying the power of sermons and
we'd like you to give this sermon on the
Good Samaritan do you know that of
course they know that and we want you to
go to from the psych lab go to the
recording studio which is down down this
alleyway and when you get there they'll
be waiting for you and we just have to
record your best sermon about the Good
Samaritan
so here good guys Princeton Theological
student may be good girls to who
thinking about being a good Samaritan
and on the way they encounter a women in
a in a hallway an alleyway
moaning clearly Anita now do they help
it turns out they help if they are told
you know you have enough time if they
told you are late please hurry
then 80% pass her by 80% of the people
princess the allowed to on the way to
give the Good Samaritan turn
three bad Samaritans if they are in a
hurry so for me that's such an important
message these days where everybody is in
a hurry we're all we all feel time press
even worse we don't even notice
somebody's moaning in a corner because
we're looking at we're walking looking
at our iPads our iPhone their iPad and
holding a Starbucks in the other hand no
absolutely and this has this has a bunch
of different paths we could travel in
this conversation I do want to talk more
about time a little bit later but just
to return to the diffusion of personal
responsibility this also has tremendous
implications for say in this relates to
the bystander effect but disaster
response and as one example I did
training here in Northern California for
nert which I believe stands for Northern
California emergency response training
or team and the San Francisco lacks the
right municipal resources to respond to
say a catastrophic very high level
earthquake
for instance they don't have the fire
engines and medical resources to contend
with a catastrophe of that skill so they
train volunteers the fire department and
police department trained volunteers to
help in such a case and one of the
things that they teach is in a group
emergency triage situation if you're if
you decide to take control of that
situation and try to lead that you never
that you always identify individuals in
the group first right and assign them
specific tasks you and you get their
attention do this you do that because if
it's a generic command to the group
nothing's gonna happen yeah I see it now
again for your listeners if we turn it
around if you are ever another victim if
you are ever hurt there are people
around you the way you get help is you
simply say you you point to someone you
with it with the green dress you were
the the brown blazer and you would you
redhead so you single them out and you
break down that that anonymity of the
group and you're much more likely to get
so what they're telling you know what
they're telling you in terms of being an
emergency respond I'm saying if you are
the victim the same principle holds
absolutely
the next is blind obedience to Authority
well you see again we are all trained as
children to obey our parents our
teachers our religious leaders in some
cases or politicians but nobody teaches
us the distinction between sorries that
deserve our respect and authorities that
do not not all parents not all menaces
we certainly know from the horrific
consequences of sexual abuse by
thousands of Catholic priests over
dozens of years that a lot of lot of
such people don't deserve a respect but
nowhere do we get training in
differentiating you know appropriate
from inappropriate authorities
authorities that deserve respect
personal stories that deserve defiance
and so so again I think in most
societies we err the direction of well
you know just obey Authority and and the
Milgram study shows how easy it is for
that to get overextended so the
authority in the Milgram study was a guy
in a white lab coat he was actually a
high school biology teacher he had he he
knew nothing about psychology he was
just recruited by a Milgram and here he
had a Milgram Milgram study they tested
a thousand people so here he had
hundreds and hundreds of adults in New
Haven Connecticut blindly following his
orders to shock more and more and he was
not an expert he just had the trappings
that the white lab coat of science so
again it's it's be wary of authorities
wearing false lab coats is there is
there any particular recommendation that
you would have for someone who wants to
train themselves to more consciously
question or assess Authority is there
any type of mental practice that you
have for yourself or question that you
ask yourself on a regular basis to help
with that I think this is a very
divisive problem that we have in the
United States and certainly not limited
to the United States right now in many
respects but if somebody wanted to train
themselves to be better at avoiding
blind obedience to Authority is there
any any particular recommendation you
would have yeah but I think it's again
questioning I mean legitimately
questioning to say why should I do that
what are the positive consequences if I
do it what are the negative consequences
oh they don't
rather than assuming if somebody says do
that because they're an authority that
without debt directly questioning their
their authority or power
I think you have to they have to the
burden has to be on them to be willing
to explain to you why you should you
should do what they say and they have to
give you a good enough reason and it
can't be because I said so I mean again
many parents say you have to do it
because I said so well at some point you
have to say that's not a reason you know
that's an opinion that's an authority
and and that and then ultimately you
have to be willing to challenge it and
when you're challenged it's already
there will be some penalties you know if
you're a kid you get slapped in the face
by it by your parents you get but I
still you have to I think you have to
practice mindful disobedience mindful
disobedience I like that the next is
uncritical conformity to group norms
yeah you know for all of us as
especially as teenagers when reforming
our identities when nothing in the world
is more important that to be popular to
have kids like us that we are willing to
become them that we dress like them the
music we like is their music our hair
whether we have tattoos whether we have
piercings you know all depends on you
know who our peer group who are in group
is and the problem is they begin to have
enormous power over us so if your peer
group begins to smoke
then chances are you going to be smoking
and if you start smoking you're going to
die young
if they are taking drugs you not only
take drug you take their kind of drug if
they are discriminating again I forgot
it's guys discriminating against girls
you do the same if the discriminating
against you know Outsiders the people
different than you so groups have
enormous power to shape our behavior our
way of thinking our attitudes as an
individual you have to separate out what
parts of that group am I willing to go
along with because I want to be accepted
I don't want to be rejected and what
parts are unacceptable that is I should
be willing to be rejected rather than to
to do some of the things that they would
like me to do one way to be aware of the
influence people have on you is to be a
deviant for a day and the simplest thing
to do is you put with a magic marker
that is erasable a square on your
forehead okay and that once you put it
on you know you look in the mirror you
see where it is and then you don't see
it anymore and people gonna say what is
that it's just it's nothing it's a
square I'm just trying something out you
begin to see very quickly how people put
pressure on you to take it off you're
not different you're not different
anyway there's a little mark on your
forehead
and so what we find is very difficult to
resist the temptation to just wipe it
off because then you're doing what they
want you to do and the idea is see if it
can resist one day 8-hours
then suddenly you realize you have this
inner power to be your own person and
and especially our parents I mean
mothers get crazy you know you're your
best friend even so come on take it off
you know it's you're embarrassing them
but you know by extension so I invite
your listeners to try the game of being
a deviant for day simply put a square
with a magic eraser or magic mark on
your forehead a small square and keep it
on for a day and just notice first the
pressure people put on you to be what
they want you to be take it off
and you'll feel the temptation to do
what they want you to do but the
learning message is that be sensitive to
the pressure of people put on you to be
what they want you to be in other ways
to like their kind of music to dress the
way they do to share in their political
views etc I just have my students at
Stanford do some things like that but
also dress dress up if you usually dress
down dress down if you dress up or do
you just do some some weird stuff and
watch how people get really upset at you
for very small deviations from what they
think is ordinary and normal so I love I
love this type of exercise and I I want
to double down and encourage just like
you did listeners to try this deviant
for a day with this with these square
the erasable is important folks don't do
this with a sharpie on your forehead and
take a photo put it on social tell us
what happened
because I hate that yeah absolutely
because these these types of I've called
them comfort challenges in the past I
think you're shocked so critical I've
had for instance some of my readers
before go to a Starbucks and just lay
down on the floor for five seconds and
then get back up and a people behave
doing something like that helps you to
inoculate yourself against harmful
conformity and that's yeah it also makes
me think a lot of Cato for instance
considered the best or the the perfect
stoic by Seneca and others yeah who
would deliberately wear say tunics of
unfashionable colors to subject himself
to ridicule so that he would learn to be
ashamed of only those things worth being
ashamed of
so I'll exactly love this idea I love
I've absolutely loved it the last one is
passive tolerance of evil through
inaction or indifference yeah so that
ties into the diffusion responsibility
again there's evil of action doing bad
things a bullying sharing prejudice
points of view but it's also
not doing it yourself but accepting by
others I always think of the case of my
uncle Charlie who had family gatherings
but tell the same jokes
it was either sexist jokes or racist
jokes and after a while people would be
horrified but no one would say to Uncle
Charlie I wish you wouldn't do it and so
one of the issues is how do you have
courageous conversations with people
like Uncle Charlie who may is probably
unaware of the negative impact he's
having partly he's been telling this
these jokes for years and years when it
was more socially acceptable and how do
you have a courageous conversation for
example to say gee uncle Charlie I love
the way you got I love the way you try
to make us all feel happy and relaxed
and tell jokes but maybe you should tell
a different kind of joke because some
people you know wouldn't understand what
you mean about black people or or women
with whether or not to have big breasts
you know and and I think we're gonna
like it even more so the key is you want
to change behavior and the kid without
the person becoming defensive and really
saying you know yeah screw you I'd do
whatever I want
no it's reminds me of a few things if
there's a quote that I really like from
ayaan Hirsi Ali she's a quote which is
tolerance of intolerance as cowardice
and I think that yeah that is certainly
one way to look at it and there's a
there's a book that is very helpful and
it's it's it might seem to be not
directly related but it does tie in
nicely there's a book called lying by
it's a very short book by Sam Harris is
a neuroscience PhD yeah I know I'm yes
and it's it's it's a it's a
fantastically powerful and concise book
about the damage done by white lies or
not speaking truth and it is it is it is
a really powerful dense
tome and in the best possible way
I'd love to it if if we have some time
to explore it I'd love to talk about the
time paradox oh sure time came up in if
in a few cases earlier and the
importance and impact of perception of
time in the case of the the goods the
the the would be good Samaritans who
when rushed eighty percent running by
the person in need and I think you've
written this that every significant
choice every important decision we make
is determined by our perception of time
this is something I'd like to explore
could you please describe for people the
the time paradox and and and and perhaps
just give them an overview of why you
wrote that book happy to do it the
reason I called my books at time paradox
which I wrote with John Boyd who now was
a Stanford graduate student that works
for face book is it's a paradox because
we're arguing that the most important
influence on all your decisions are the
big ones and small ones and decisions
that leads with leans you to your
actions is something inside of you that
you're unaware of and what it is it's
your sense of time perspective and time
perspective is the way you categorize
and partition your sense of time into
categories a pet the big ones a past
president future and what what we've
discovered is it's much more complex and
subtle so that all of us live in
multiple time zones for some of us if I
ask you tell me about your past tell me
your recollections of your childhood
tell me your recollections of what
happened last year for some people their
answers are always focused around all
the good things good times could award
successes birthday parties for others
it's all the negatives failures regrets
things you could have done I should have
done abuse of various ways and we now
can categorize those as people who live
in the past positive or past negative
and then when I ask you about
your present for some people people we
call present hedonist will outline all
the fun things they do all the pleasures
they get out of life seeking knowledge
seeking sensation seeking novelty other
people are present fatalists they say it
doesn't pay to plan for the future I
don't control anything my life is
controlled by fate and this is true if
you're Muslim Allah controls your future
now there two ways to be future so one
future orientation is probably most of
your listeners focus on what do I have
to do now to achieve objectives and
goals that will take place in the future
so these are positive future future of
hope future of possibilities there's not
two other ways to be future oriented one
is a future negative that you're anxious
will I be able to see will I be able to
achieve and so the future instead of
being filled with hope is filled with
anxiety and be future oriented is weak
all transcendental future that I live my
life so that when I die I will go to
heaven rather than hell and so it's a
different kind of system I'm not seeking
success I'm seeking behaving in a way to
be seen as a good person on on Judgment
Day and I've developed a scale with
Zimbardo time perspective inventory z
TPI which which when you take it it
gives you scores on each of these
dimensions and if you go to my website
it's the time paradox calm you can take
the scale and you get to get immediate
feedback on your scores now what's
critical is we've discovered with lots
and lots of research is that the most
important thing in life is to have what
we call a balanced time perspective be
TP which means being high on past
positive being moderately high on future
so that you're not a workaholic a
positive future and being moderate on
present hedonism which is selected when
you do as a reward for doing achieving
good deeds with your future orientation
so there's lots of research that show
people have high a balanced time
perspective are physically healthier
psychologically healthier achieve more
that always in this is research from
around the world are these are much
these are the most successful people
psychologically and with even within the
business world so this research that I
started back in nineteen I guess about
2000 we now have an international time
perspective group hundreds and hundreds
of young researchers and in many
countries around the world we meet
biannually in Portugal and Warsaw and a
Copenhagen next next year we'll meet in
Marseille meet and talk about research
we're doing and it's not just research
it's application so these ideas are in
psychotherapy and family therapy and and
clearly in business so on and so it's
something I'm really proud of that just
a little research idea and as I said
partly came out of the Stanford Prison
Experiment where everybody sent some
time was distorted because because the
evil of the guards and they made every
hour feel they feel like you know name
many many many more hours what are some
of the changes that readers of the time
paradox have made in their own lives or
that attendees for instance at the time
perspective conference have made in
their own lives as a result of this work
does anything come to mind oh for sure
I mean wait you know for people who live
in the past negative in the extreme this
is post-traumatic stress disorder
you know one third of all American vets
coming back from Iraq from Afghanistan
are suffering with PTSD which is which
in traditional treatment is
incurable we drug them keep it from
getting worse we've developed a time
perspective therapy in with my
colleagues in Maui Ric and rosemary
sword in which we are able in eight
sessions till quote cure in our sample
was like thirty two vets with extreme
case of PTSD and part of it is teaching
them about the psychology of time
perspective and converting each of those
negatives into a positive yes of course
you know it's not it's not it's not
undermining the negative it's best buddy
died in your arms yes you saw children
being sexually abused but now we're
going to do is we're going to put in
positive slides in your slide tray using
an old metaphor you know did you did
your family write to you while you're
there did you make any friends did you
do did you do any good deeds so now
clearly what's happening people have
this negative time perspective they have
just loaded up they've just exaggerated
and miss focused on a few negatives as
if that's what well there was even
people have had abuse and life of that
had that literally had some real abuse
you say you know we want you we were to
help you elaborate on all the good
things in your life yes so one teacher
embarrass you tell us about all the
teachers who praise you tell us about
all the teachers who made you feel
special so again it's literally possible
if you understand this I call your time
perspectives change your own time
perspective your time perspective of
others so again in the time paradox and
the our other book is called the time
cure we give very specific suggestions
if you want to be more future oriented
here's what you can do if you want to be
again the problem with being too future
oriented is you become a workaholic so
how do you put some present hedonism joy
into your life and so again I try I
tried to go from being a general
researcher trying to discover how the
mind and bite and behavior work
- always saying how can we use these
ideas to make our life better richer
more productive and and simply to take
joy in being a human being I mentioned
before we started recording but the the
fact that I received a early galley copy
of the time paradox it must have been in
my child right 2008 or very late 2007 I
think 2008 and I I found it very
impactful and underlined a lot in that
book and I ended up among other things
in the each each morning and this is a
recent implementation but I have a five
minute journal routine where I try to
present state ground myself with a few
things like gratitude bullets and so on
before going on to the goal-setting so
that I'm not anxious and constantly
future focused but one of the
affirmations so to speak that I found
most helpful is I am unrushed and this
this this this comes back directly to
the story about the the Good Samaritans
right from the Theological Seminary and
it's proven to be incredibly therapeutic
for me I would encourage people to check
out the time paradox I thought I found
it to be a brilliant exploration and it
also a lot of what you've written about
corresponds to one of the most powerful
exercises that I've experienced and
studied of Tony Robbins he has a process
that calls the Dickens process and the
Dickens process refers to the ghosts of
of Christmas past present and future I
and and taking people through these
different tenses in a number of respects
to like you said replace or at least
augment some of the slides in their
current slideshow yeah that's a great I
mean again we we all tell the story of
you know Dickens and Scrooge and living
in the past present and future the point
is
we have to we have to combine those that
how do we when we think about the past
how do we embellish it and rich it when
we but we want to enjoy we want to live
in the moment we want to enjoy the
present of family friends fun in the we
now know the importance of spending time
outside in the natural environment not
living at our desks you know or in our
cell cell phone' environment and again
we want to have hope possibility is in
the future how do we shape our past and
present to make us ready to enjoy the
best in the future and also to think the
future is always shapeable modifiable by
our actions now the other thing I should
add here is that one of the ideas we I
promote in the heroic imagination
project is we are most effective in in
teams in small groups
I call them hero squads so when you want
to challenge authority when you do it
alone the authority dismisses you as a
fanatic when you have three or more
people who agree with you and you
confront Authority then it is a point of
view when you say we believe sir that
what you're doing is not appropriate is
not in our best interest
they can't dismiss you individually so
again when when you're challenging
unjust Authority in the classroom in an
organization and the church whatever it
is it is always better to do it as part
of a small operating team is the
defining difference between heroism and
altruism the resistance of some type of
authority figure or authority is it is
that one of the differentiators no no
the key the key between altruism is
doing social good heroism is doing a
civic virtue the differences
altruism is heroism light the key the
key is to be a hero it's to take action
on behalf of others in need or defending
a moral cause and the key now is aware
of potential risks and costs to you so I
give I give blood to blood bank I give
money to homeless speak up people who
are homeless I do I work in a soup
kitchen it doesn't cost me anything
except a little bit of time so in the
extreme of heroism you die okay you lose
you risk your life you rip life and limb
whistleblowers often lose their job I
don't get promoted but the key is just a
perception I'm doing this despite the
fact that there could be a cost that
there's some potential risk to me and
even though I'm aware of that
nevertheless I continue to do it if you
have five minutes oh I have all the time
in the world I just want to be
respectful of your time I definitely
have time so I I in this last thing with
the Prison Experiment and the reason why
I ended this study and is also ties to
heroism
so the Stanford Prison study I was
scheduled to go for two weeks I I could
have really gone more than a week I
probably would have gone
it started on Sunday I probably would
have gone to the following Sunday to
make it you know a full week partly
because it was overwhelmingly stressful
it wasn't clear to me what it meant to
have an experiment that runs night and
day continuously and with me to graduate
Sue's and one undergraduate and then one
graduate suit had to leave in the middle
of the study had a family emergency so
we have me and two students working 24/7
Chris's are having a breakdown every
single day parents are coming for
visiting day there's parole board
hearings for prisoners who want to want
to leave there's visiting a prison
chaplains there's rumor of escape plan
there's all these things happening and
of course I'm in charge and I'm sleeping
on a couch in my office on the second
floor the psychology department Jordan
Hall and so I know who I was stressed
but
I'm gonna keep it probably keep it going
till to the weekend and then on Thursday
night
my girlfriend Christina Maslach who had
been a graduate student at Stanford who
just got a job at Berkeley to start in
September said she was working at the
Stanford library and you know could we
have dinner in the evening so I had to
come down on Thursday night so study
started August 14th 1971 so this is like
five days in and I said you know come
down and then we'll go out to dinner and
what she sees is but it's listed on my
schedule as the ten o'clock toilet run
at ten o'clock was the last time
prisoners could go to a real toilet
after that they had a urinate and
defecate in a bucket in the cell which
they hated to do because it smelled
terrible so the guards used the guards
on the night shift and the night shift
was was the worst one
just as in Abu Ghraib the night shift
was was we're all the disaster took
place partly because they thought nobody
was looking that the guards lined the
prisoners up put bags for paper bags
over the head chained their legs
together started yelling and cursing and
you know abusing them in every way this
is that Stanford I'd say this is in the
Stanford Prison Experiment right and the
same thing in Abu Ghraib but in the same
physics range so I look up I'm looking
through one you know one way he's screen
and for me it's a checkmark on my daily
schedule you know eight o'clock
breakfast 10 o'clock visiting day
12 o'clock lunch two o'clock parole in
here it's a 10 o'clock toilet room and I
look like my Christina I say hey look at
that isn't it interesting she begins to
tear up and runs out runs out to the
quad in front of Jordan hall Sam and I
run out we have this big argument I'm
saying you don't understand the dynamics
of human nature nobody's seen seen this
before in action etc and she says stop
these are not prisoners these are not
guards they're boys and they are
suffering and you are responsible and
then she says you have been changed by
the power of the situation more than
anyone and how could you not see the
stuff
is obvious and I'm still arguing and
then she said stop if this is the real
you I don't think I want to continue my
romantic relationship with you we had
just moved in together we've thinking of
you know living together then getting
married and so so the tie back to the
point I made so this is heroism in
action she's saying I'm willing to pay
the cost of giving up a lifetime with
you and you know we were very much in
love if you don't come to your senses
now she never said you have to end this
study she just said you know you know
you have to realize you know that that
your perception is being distorted by
the role you were playing as prison
superintendent and at that moment I said
oh my god you're right we had dinner
like midnight and then I ended the study
the next day so so this is it the best
example I know of heroism an action an
ordinary person you know a former
student confronting Authority and just
making it clear that you know that she
is willing to pay this price you know in
order to challenge this moral injustice
that what that was that was happening
that is a great story and I think it's I
think it's a great place to wrap up for
for today this installment we're
practically neighbors so be lovely to
knock person at some point but I I
really appreciate you taking the time
dr. Zimbardo this has been a a dream
conversation of mine for a very long
time so I really appreciate you carving
out the time in your schedule he seemed
to be as as as occupied and engaged as
ever with the world I should mention
that that I no longer I teach at
Stanford maybe once a year I give a
model lecture to introductory psych
I taught more students and more
different courses than any professor in
Stanford history I had classes of over a
thousand students in an introductory
psych but now I go around the world and
I do I do training in our heroic
imagination project in Hungary and
Poland in Sicily
in Czech Republic in Bali and Australia
so so I keep busy duties certainly do
and you you taught you well you taught
for I guess 57 years is that right we're
tired after officially retired after
teaching for certainly 50-plus years but
you're still teaching that's the beauty
of it you've just chosen a different a
different vehicle through which to teach
and first foremost thank you for for
jumping on the phone and after everybody
listening you can find the show notes
links to all of these books articles
studies and so on as usual in the show
notes where you can find links to every
other episode as well at 4-hour workweek
comm forward slash podcast all spelled
out and until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by ID
Commerce and logistics known these guys
for quite a while I'm asked all the time
about how to scale businesses quickly
and rule of a1 is removing bottlenecks
that slow you down and act as an
emergency brake for many companies one
of the first things this should go is
inventory management and fulfillment ID
commerce and logistics focuses on
helping
online retailers and entrepreneurs
outgrow the competition by handling all
the behind-the-scenes details that you
don't want to they manage your inventory
pick pack and ship and handle every
possible logistics need so that you can
focus on what you're good at and the
other aspects of growing your business I
partnered with them myself during the
launch of the 4-hour chef so that I
could focus on promoting the book what
I'm good at and they ensured they
handled what they're good that is
keeping my readers happy with the dozens
of different products that needed to be
shipped out during holiday crunch season
before Christmas I'd ecommerce and
logistics works with many types of
businesses including ecommerce consumer
packaged goods subscription boxes and
dozens more and they're integrated with
top ecommerce platform such as Shopify
my personal favorite Magento BigCommerce
and others which makes the set up the
integration partnership all seamless and
as a listener of this podcast you can
get up to ten thousand dollars of
startup fees and costs waived that is a
huge discount so check it out you can go
to Ivy comluv.com forward slash Tim
that's ID c om l OG com forward slash
tim or you can go to tim dot blog
forward slash scale that's tim dot blog
forward slash scale this episode is
brought to you by wealth front wealth
front is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high end financial advice that the
best private wealth managers delivered
to the ultra wealthy but for any account
size and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers and the
software wealth front now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost
hassle-free way to invest
they don't upload its sales teams or
retail locations so they can deliver all
of this sophisticated financial advice
and these services at a fraction of the
cost of a traditional financial advisor
so at the very least go to wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim and take their
free risk assessment survey it only
takes a couple of minutes and
wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go to wealthfront compo it's
on Tim to get your first 15k managed for
free or just to get more details check
it out
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim
you